[Musique]
sk l'outre-mer et la nouvelle exposition
itinérante de la rue de paris devant les
bâtiments du département le passant est
invité à contempler les trésors naturels
de l'outre-mer et parmi les huit
photographes rényoné des influenceurs
des hommes de talent qui archive et nous
donne le regard qu'ils voient là la
beauté des décès outremer la richesse
mondiale et ce tous que les gens
prennent conscience que c'est une beauté
qui est belle est aussi très fragile
qu'il faut préserver
passée la performance artistique
le ton change car cette exposition est
une énième opportunité de nous saisir
dit non j'ai un travail mené au
quotidien par les services du
département à travers la gestion des
92130 6 hectares de la forêt deux
partenaires domaniale connaissant
connaître c'est à dire qu on a tous
l'impression connaître qui trouvèrent là
tous l'impression de connaître la nature
mais qu'est ce qu'on connaît maman est
ce qu on sait que 80 % de la
biodiversité est ultra marines en france
est ce qu'on sait que la france se situe
au 4e rang mondial de la biodiversité
avec ça lui confère une responsabilité
majeure en termes de protection des
espèces on peut prendre l'exemple du
blizzard de maillard le papangue qu'il
sera pas sur notre île à la réunion si
la femme disparaît il règne et il
disparaît à l'échelle de la planète des
territoires exceptionnel un patrimoine
naturel inestimable le département
sensible sur la chance que nous avons
sur le territoire accompagne
naturellement cette démarche si on
touche les coeurs par le haut il faut
monter jusqu'à la tête jusqu à l'esprit
pour dire quels fruits dans le même
temps préservons et surtout retissant n'
ya différentes re de la nature et une
image on l'exploité voir trouve
surexploitées si on fait pas gaffe
demain cette surexploitation nous mènera
notre père ce qu'ils font est donc notre
biodiversité s'appauvrit et
jusqu'à quand donc moi j'ai des maux et
qui sont conscientes vigilance éducation
et responsabilité de tous cette
exposition ne changera pas tout même si
le message semble simple chacun doit
poser une pierre à l'édifice qu'est ce
grand combat pour la protection de notre
planète
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]